good afternoon my name is dr. Claude
mallet from waters corporation and today
I will be talking about a topic that is
in my opinion the novel aspect of
chromatography in this case
multi-dimensional chromatography it's
perceived as a absolutely disruptive
technology kind of a net flix effect as
I call it throughout this presentation
you will see that there will be a lot of
statement that will cause a disruptive
idea what if this case will be here you
can see that earth was perceived to be
flat years ago when [ __ ] actually
round by disruptive ideas you have one
over here that I think is probably the
best one that can actually found is a
scenario that we've changed drastically
on how we entertain herself
Netflix basically came with some of the
best technology and without looking at
this from technology we have a scenario
that one could remain complacent now how
is that relate to chromatography well in
this case will be here you'll see in the
next few slides but a lot of users will
see this type of issue happen I need
more sensitivity here now the problem
with laco chromatography is there's a
scenario of mass overload and volume
overload so I have a very narrow window
of opportunity to gain or actually
produce a peak shape Gaussian
distribution that it connects utilize
for both quantitative and qualitative
analysis if I inject more I'll basically
get peak distortions in the mass
overload when try to amass and Jack lot
more volume or mass we have what called
the shark fin profile or tailing profile
for volume overload so there's a
limitation that we
the next aspect is I need more
resolution unfortunately chromatography
is and will be needed to be connected to
some fort of sample prep a lot of sample
prep will lead to very complex extracts
this leads to a scenario of how much
entity do I have in a mixture in how
much separation power do I get to
separate now depending on the type of
application a lot of time we have as I
explained to concept I need more
sensitivity and I need more resolution
so how do I do that next slide shows
what chromatography is used for so
chromatography is a technique that we
used to separate it's actually sent to
some sort of detection could be optical
or disruptive but it requires to have a
some sort of work flow in front of it
sample prep that's actually the dreadful
scenario I have to utilize techniques
and protocols or methods to isolate the
target and like we want to analyze out
of a huge huge matrix complexity now
here I've actually separated the class
in three class the type of sample matrix
now a Class A would be considered a low
matrix here we can see an example like
drinking water a Class B would be a
liquid solid type of mixture
it could be fruit juice could be
biological fluids and a C class are
basically solids could be tissue could
be a soil could be food applications but
as the complexity of the sample
increases the task to extract said
analyte either for target application or
screen becomes really
complex events the for for a method
preparation now the simple prep works
something of this nature was actually at
least five key step that needs to be
done before we start obviously we have
to collect a sample as we see in the
upper left corner then we have
measurement we weigh we transform a raw
sample into an ideal format but either
LC or GC can actually utilize now on the
right hand side corner we have the
extraction process concentrate we clean
with filter and then we do Stickley go
through a solvent conversion that is
compatible with a technique of liquid
chromatography most case you'll see but
most final extract will vary between 500
microliters to 1 mil and a 2 mil vial or
the 1 mil 96-well plate is basically the
format that we need to put our raw
sample into a ideal format that we can
inject that is basically a very lengthy
extraction process now when I started my
career back in the early 80s extraction
was done in a very very lengthy process
we can actually spend hours sometimes
days of extraction this over here is an
example of a setup
that when solid-state extraction came on
the market back in the late 80s early
90s they change radically how we do
sample prep back then but the concept
remains the same a lot of time we will
need to do either an interest rate
process we'll need to do a lot of step
to clean the sample and to have an
extract that's actually of good quality
that we can actually get decent results
or satisfactory results now in this case
we'll be here back in the early 90s this
is how I used to
work with protocols back then it was a
one for example for drinking water or
water analysis we would basically
extract 1 liter finish with 1 mil then
this gives us the 1000 to 1 in Richard
process of which we use 10 to 20
microliters for injections in fact we're
using about 1% of our work for the final
analysis finally interesting is that 23
years later as a savvy user in chemistry
I'm still using the same protocol
technology has changed mass spectrometry
increase in sensitivity chromatography
increase in speed but the sample prep
remained the same that's actually where
you start realizing that when we look at
instrumentation for example the next
slides you'll see that traditional
versus innovative you will see that on
the upper hand that's how I was
introduced back in 2000 when lc/ms came
to the market a lot of folks will
actually get best mass spec on the
market the best HPLC and over the course
of a decade
you have novelties in both mass
spectrometry and chromatography but
interesting enough in the sample prep
area we have exactly the same scenario
it hasn't changed
now where this will go let's take a look
at the next slides why is it that we can
inject more well it's obviously over
here we can see that the one dlc
limitation we have a serious injection
volume issue so now when we try to
inject more the system is actually
choking up and we can't get decent peak
shape and it will become distorted
volume overload and we also see a
retention return strength time shift as
we can see
now also this is actually the standard
aqueous extract or initial mobile phase
most applications will require or we use
rather a reverse face type of
chromatography meaning that we'll start
with a initial mobile phase in aqueous
condition most likely between one and
five percent and use the organic
modifiers for a Lucian profile now this
is basically what happens so aqueous
standard but what happens if we try to
inject a straight-up 100% organic as one
would expect we have total breakthrough
why there's actually no retention even
if I inject large volume it's not gonna
make any difference I still and will
always have a large volume injection a
this case a breakthrough so now we have
here a scenario of what if those issue
could be solved by a disruptive
technology and this is actually where on
these slides here you're gonna see that
multi-dimensional chromatography by
adding extra fluid Inc circuitry and
also adding extra component will bring
novel aspect that a user can infuse or
include in their workflow however
multi-dimensional chromatography is not
a new technique per se it is a technique
has been around for decades but it
actually has a very bad reputation
the reputation at hand over here is when
we go from a one-dimensional
chromatography unit to a multi V there's
two myth that I'll see or one we'll see
coming up more often one is it will be
too difficult to understand meaning that
I cannot utilize this one and the second
myth is because of that difficult to
understand it will be very difficult to
operate install troubleshoot
and produce decent results well this is
actually what this presentation is all
about so let's go into the heart of the
topic and this presentation is actually
designed to give a heads up as to what
is out there what we would need to go
and some of the benefits of actually
adding extra unit in this case will be
here
entry level multi D would be as easy as
adding one extra pump if we can go
further go ballistic then yes we can
actually add more components so it
becomes more complex but with today's
software everything can be controlled
now the multi dimension liquid
chromatography option number one so how
do I increase resolution now resolution
is increased by simply connecting two
columns together now we're trying to
avoid what we call these serial
connectors now in this diagram will be
here in the middle and the green box
I've actually put a standard connector
now what we want to do over here is
utilize or introduce a concept of a
separate of dimension what would
actually avoid actually give a
resolution gain and avoid a Quay Lucian
aspect now there's several definition
but there's actually two definition of
multi dimension that basically opens up
or actually comes more often definition
number one a resolving or separate of
dimension is any column chemistry's with
particle size less than five microns so
basically we're looking at a high
resolution separation also there's
actually a more relaxed definition
meaning that any dimension capable of a
separation either coarse or high can be
perceived as a bonafide
dimension so now we're looking also at
concept called trap columns and in this
case will be here we're trying to avoid
any type of cell connection because this
case will be here it
the same thing as adding extra lengths
adding the length does not necessarily
means I'll have more resolution now the
predominant technique and
multi-dimension forma tog Rafi is what
we call the dual loop injection also
known as comprehensive chromatography
now this concept here is interesting to
utilize what's actually very fairly
simple to operate and to understand now
the concept will be here is that on the
left hand side restrain you're going to
have your standard injection one pump
goes into a resolving dimension now that
dimension flow rate is purposely float a
slowed down and will be diverted to a an
injection port on the middle of the
screen that goes to two loops now those
loop will oscillate between loop number
one the bottom and the top one number
two so there's actually a fill rate of
dimension one on to loop one has to be
equal to the aleutian rate of loop two
on to dimension two so now basically
what we're looking for is a multiple
heart cut so we're gonna take a
chromatogram and we're gonna slice those
chromatogram in distinct packet it's
called a duty cycle so now the fill rate
has to be equal to the aleutian rate so
now the second dimension will always be
of larger ID with larger flow rate that
will incorporate a dilution factor
usually we'll have between one and two
minute duty cycle so what will happen is
something of this nature in this slides
you can see that we have here a very
complex resolution on dimension one and
we're losing in this case a very very
shallow gradient that could last one to
two hours depending on the type of
resolution we're looking for then what
we're going to do here by sing out the
second valve between loop 1 and loop 2
then we can oscillate between a floor
injection rate and a lucien rate between
the 2 dimension so now by using a
hundred macula loop in this case will be
here we will have a one minute duty
cycle so we're doing a one minute cut at
constant interval what happens is
something of this nature we have here a
typical contour plot utilized with UV
detectors so now we have the resolving
dimension 1 & 2 and we have a top view
of where your comp interest would be
resolved so now the contour plot will be
here you can see that everything that
has a high red value would be a
separation and all these blue Regent
would actually means there's nothing
there now one aspect of comprehensive
chromatography in this case will be here
it's a one of the first iteration of
this technique and we can see that it
does increase the peak capacity or
resolution capacity most time what
happens is that you're gonna have a lot
of tailing you can see that in the
bottom hand corner Peaks basically looks
pretty wide now this is actually nothing
more than adding a resolution factor
it's pretty significant but more can be
done in multi D chromatography there is
a major impact that we can now start
looking into really closely so when you
PLC or ultra-high performance from Atari
fie came in the mid 2000 it basically
changed how one would do HPLC now our
long method were replaced by five to ten
minute applications multi-dimension will
have the same type of impact that you
PLC had versus HPLC but a will happen at
the simple prep area so now instead of
actually spending hours and sometime
days of extraction we can anticipate and
look at applications I always go along
in this presentation that will showcase
interesting aspect and also disruptive
aspect on how to operate and how to use
these technology better now the second
option with multi D is to increase the
separation performance and the workflow
so in this case will be here we will add
the concept of what we call a trap
column trap column is different from a
annika column in a sense that we can see
first Hardware is exactly the same the
only difference will be here we have a
call a Direct Connect that we can
basically reduce some of the dead volume
but the predominant aspect is the
particle and the solvent that these trap
columns are packed with now if one
remembers your vending to curve or your
the particle size will have a impact on
your separation so now the lower de
particle the higher your separation
power now in this case we hear these
trapped columns will be used to refocus
a part cut from a dimension any type of
dimension and to allow a reinjection
onto another type of dentin now in this
case over here those trap column will
allow to operate to resolve in dimension
in a static approach as opposed to a
dynamic that we see with the two loops
configuration now with the trap column
as opposed to a Luke injection we can
spend a lot more time ensuring that a
target analyte can be refocused properly
with the proper condition
for it reach your second dimension now
in this case over here we will see a
couple of scenarios of how these trap
columns are used and how effective those
can be utilized in of various different
configurations now the concept with a
trap column as the name said it's not
utilized for resolution it's actually
there for a certain purpose now the
first aspect of a trap columns that we
can utilize this one in several ways
I'll explain as we go along now on this
side over here we can see that we have
two chromatogram the left one is a
hundred percent aqueous standard that
was injected into a single stream
aqueous loading now when we look at the
chromatogram on the right we have here a
hundred percent ACN standard or extract
as to be expected we see peak distortion
now what's the proper of actually using
trap column versus unequal column if the
problem remains the same the aspect
behind it is actually what's going to
happen on the next slide now here
instead of our using what we call a
single stream loading we're going to use
what we call a dual stream we will add a
dilution factor into it meaning that on
the left-hand left side you're gonna see
your injection loop that's actually
where you would put your extract but
before the extract reaches the column it
will be diluted to a ratio of about
twenty to one that means that by
manipulating as I seen in this slide I
have now a second pump now that's
actually where the complexity perception
resides where do I put those pumps and
how many pumps can actually control this
actually depends on software but the
concept
here's that we have a loading that will
push the entire extract out of the
sample loop and reconnect with a
diluting verses via route say a mixer
and by playing with the flow rate of
loader deluder I can now dial in a
proper dilution ratio at 5% it means
that anything that would be at 100%
organic it could be an IPA could be an
ACN the methanol and acetone anything
that's actually water-soluble solvent
would be dropped at 5% before it reached
a trap that means that we're can work in
effect creating a either credit
condition now the interesting aspect is
that now that I have a dual stream
loading with what we call it at column
dilution it doesn't matter if I have an
aqueous or organic or any percentage of
a go organic any quiz could be 50 50 25
75 doesn't matter 100% the compound of
interest will be refocused in the proper
condition on a solvent that's compatible
for the separation that comes further so
now with this aspect if we capture the
chromatogram here now we have a scenario
that in this instance I have four
chromatograms the bottom two are single
dimension the standard 20 microliters
and I have a 250 some time by increasing
the columns ID I can have a efficient
retention that's not always the case now
when we look at a 2d system basically is
a trap in a looped up a configuration
with two columns now if I use a single
stream loading with the humps and water
then I can see that the retention time
will be a bit more longer that's because
of the dilution factor or the loading
factor from the
trap that has to be counted in now by
using a an AK convolution concept we can
see that we have a much higher loading
rate but actually avoids any evaporation
of dryness as we're gonna see in the
next few slides so now this is actually
water extracts we can see that every
technique will give absolutely good
results now this one here is interesting
because by adding a hundred percent ACN
extract we can see that on a 1 D 20
microliters on the 3 D 25 microliters we
basically have breakthrough as to be
expected now with large foam injection
on the single stream we see we have a
split cake on the third chromatogram
from the bottom now we can see that
that's basically means because it counts
a compound of interest is still
surrounded with a lot of organic
molecules now with the dilution factor
of about 20 to 1 also we can see that in
this case we can have a absolutely
fantastic Gaussian peak shape but we
actually found a way to have a signal
increase so now when we look at simple
prep this becomes absolutely fantastic
so let's basically look at the next
slides and you'll see that with a
multi-dimensional chromatography
workflow we can go into a simple prep
and find ways on how to use this simple
configuration for optimizing a novel
workflow for example when we use a
sample prep for the extraction of let's
say pharmaceutical or pesticide in
drinking water or surface or water
application we would have in the blue
box basically scenario that we have to
condition the solvent before we can load
the compounds because in this case we
here the conditioning and wetting step
would remove any prospect extract
the mullah leachable from the sorbets
know we have to remember this
not all SB sorbents I Creek read equal
there's actually lot of manufacturers
that will not take care on they're not
simple prep but their manufacturing
processes that's the reason why we wash
the sorbents first with very hard and a
large cocktail of solvent to clean out
everything the ACN dichloromethane is
just one of several move towards a
solvent that's more soluble in water and
then finished with water that will be
compatible with my sample of interest
now we have a loading aspect so now
we're going to load our sample onto our
solvent and also have here an enrichment
process so depending on the injection
volume of the loading volume we're going
to look at this one versus what's gonna
be at the end now the wash step over
here is done with various percentage of
water organic the wash step is there to
remove impurities interferences but to
keep the sample of interest lock on the
solvent is actually several techniques
to do that we can use a standard reverse
phase stop mechanism there's also an
exchange or even mix modes with the
polymer based SPE
we can actually utilize what we call an
air drying step to remove all water
molecule out of the final extract that
we can new a much better and efficient
illusion and but the same process it
would reduce the amount of time to
evaporate the organic layer and
reconstitute in initial mobile phase now
this is actually where a lot of
extraction will finish it's actually a
common point for reverse phase
chromatography because we start with a
rough or raw sample it goes into an
organic layer that organic layer has to
be brought back down to dryness and
reconstitute an initial mobile phase now
usually the evaporation dryness and
reconstitute can actually
coughed up about 40% of any extraction
method some time you've ever and dryness
could take several hours I've seen over
the years application that will go up to
a button overnight
drawing stuff which is actually very
lengthy now with the fact that I can
inject with a dual stream trap column
combination with an aqua column now this
large Roma injection of aqueous and
organic basically disappeared
that's a disruptive aspect so how can I
use this now in this case will be here
if I take my same method without
changing anything it means that I can
take any aliquot of any step and look at
real-time what is exactly is happening I
can utilize either a target application
I can basically look at a target
molecule but could also look at what
else is involved with my compound of
interest when I interacted with an SV
solvent for example on the condition I
can take the acetone the methanol and
the water wash and analyze all those to
see if there's any type of leachable x'
that would be present in that particular
sorban then at all the wash step
regardless if their water base or
organic base doesn't matter
those can be injected directly without
any to that for the dryness at all then
I can take in this case two streams I
can take
directly the final illusion and see if
my company of interest is in there and
also look at the final aqueous and look
at the difference between a any quiz
injection versus an organic extract a
lot of time that's actually where you're
gonna see issues with evaporated dryness
what we call evaporative loss and we
just read your solution problems
especially for trace level analysis
usually an organic layer would actually
and will give much better result now bay
on that aspect we can go in and optimize
our extraction procedure we'll actually
see exactly what needs to be seen now
after all is done we can also utilize
multi D for extreme cost-saving in term
of resource time and consumable for
example the protocol on the left is the
standard protocol that one would need to
use with a 1d method now on a two-column
chemistry or 2d as I call it one could
utilize a drastic aspect for multiple
things now because we can inject larger
volume and organic and also aqueous it
gives options to keep the same
enrichment process or actually increase
the enrichment process while saving time
because I don't have to evaporate you
join us I can actually take the final
element and inject as much as I need to
reach my injection level so I can inject
between up to 500 microliters up to 1
milliwatt in this case if we allude
within this application we can
anticipate that by alluding with 1 mil
Sen from a 20 mil loading we have in
this case a 20 to 1 enrichment frost
process now injecting 100 microliters or
even up to 250 it'll give a user
multiple time to do replicate injection
from the same vial in this case we'll be
here we're using a lot more of our work
so the overall performance is that we
can now eliminate dry time the
evaporation step reconstitution and also
reduced the amount of elusion solvent
per extraction spite of using a 5 mil we
can use a 1 mil
in this case the enrichment process here
is actually quite interesting to look at
in this case will be here we've injected
I set up a system that has both a UV
detector for vitamin b12 and then I
actually put the mass spec in series
under under scan mode
now usually PDAs will have the texture
limit at around 1 ppm this over here is
a 1 mil injection of a 1 ppb now we can
see that PDA can see a very defined peak
shape and confirm by the scan mode from
the thousand to one enrichment now this
here was an aqueous extract and we have
the exact same thing with an organic
extra so now we have choices and this
actually choices allows to utilize
several conditions for method
development and actually create a
methodology for applications so that's
actually where we're gonna spend a bit
more time on how to optimize retention
now and this side over here we have a
two column chemistry dimension one
dimension to dimension one is our trap
dimension 2 is our separation now we
have here concept of a loader deluder
pump that's actually a first circuit for
the trap now on the right hand side we
have our injector loop that would come
from the outer sampler then we add an
extra switch valve that actually will
create a a connector between the loading
circuit and the aleutian circuit now
each circuitry here will have conditions
that needs to be addressed now we need
to understand how to load and how to
elute and we need to understand which
trapping chemistry's and which
separation chemistry's
now it couldn't be a daunting task if we
look at the next slides over here and
then we look at these four parameters
we've look here at a scenario that we
have well over permutations that would
be nearly impossible to analyze all of
them
400-plus well what if we could start
with the top 36 that gives here a
starting point these are the ones that I
usually use for most of application that
I work with and I start with what we
call the 36 top methods that I will
basically create into a grid called the
6x6 grid this allows to understand and
to go through the process of looking at
how to optimize methods now in the world
of multi-dimensional chromatography one
will be confronted with the concept of
what we call multi residue application
versus the concept of multi-method
application now multi residue is kind of
a situation that was a necessary evil
because of lengthy extraction process
and it becomes very difficult to find
several target analytes that behave
exactly the same now that's actually
where multi residue comes in because of
sample prep being very complex and very
lengthy it becomes impossible to extract
for every single compounds in a single
dimension now with multi D we since the
sample prep protocol can be downsized by
a factor at least of ten perhaps even
more we can spend a lot more time or
focus on novel sample prep and optimize
sample prep according to a target
analyte condition now let me explain in
this case will be here I've actually
created what I call a method development
it's actually a scenario
the system any system that we have can
be automated to look at multiple target
parameters now depending on how much
time we can use now for example in the
blue box we have here a scenario that we
use three retention strengths on the
trap on dimension one so we use the low
retention material this case a simple
Celica c18 we use also in the middle a
no c8 versus a c18 in the middle and we
use a polymer on the back end that has a
lot more retention strengths also we're
gonna vary the pH pH 3 7 and 10 now that
particular square will be alluded off
the traps or these traps with a standard
ACN mobile phase at low pH onto a
seating columns now here we have nine
methods that looks at retention strength
and loading pH on the first dimension
now when we would add a three by six we
can add an illusion from a low pH to a
high pH solution depending on the
compounds structure chemical and
physical property now when we add an
illusion polarity we can switch from a a
solution to a methanol illusion now
depending on how much time we have
usually a six five six rate will take
about 24 hours to complete meaning that
you have system with today's automation
can run 24/7 without stop so what do we
get out of this one is something of this
nature now for example in this
particular scenario I have a target
analyte which is basically a THC
metabolite this case a meet Anaka and
the aspect over here is that we have a
our first grid in this case will be here
we have the 6 by 3 so from it's a 10 to
method 18 so I have on the left hand
side my pH 3 7 10 and I have my CH the
18 in polymer so now I can see how this
compound of interest will fare at any
given time so now I have in this case
good resolution and good separation or
in this case just a camp on an interest
I have good peak shake but I can
actually choose which method will give
the highest intensity so now in this
case I would actually chosen methods
oven is also method 17 or method 12 but
anything that gives a higher a high 90
percent can be chosen now
the extraction that was actually telling
about between a aqueous and organic
injecting organic extract will have
another level of sensitivity increase
for example if I look at in this case a
coking extraction from a urine and or in
feta mean if I go from a water
extraction final dilution versus of a
methanol ACN I can see that I have here
a huge increase by going to methanol
versus water now here the aspect of a
how can we explain that one this one is
explained by the fact that at trace
levels anything below PPV range you
start to have absorption issues on any
type of active surface especially glass
well once we basically have all these
chromatogram these results we can create
a method identification portfolio
understanding where the compound of
interest resides so by looking at a
screen shot in this case will be here
we're looking at a microsystem
application we did a few years ago this
case we are you're gonna see that we
have a water methanol and an ACN
Ellucian final illusion in this case
now we notice that on average between
the aqueous extract versus a methanol
ACN all across the board we're seeing
about a 10x increase in sensitivity also
we're going in through the process of
looking at every chromatogram at
actually assigning a a profile so now if
we have a Gaussian peak shape we put in
that method a green box anything that
gives a signal but would basically give
either tail leave split broad would
actually be yellow meaning that I can
see if week but it's not of good nature
I could probably use a method like that
for identification but mostly for
quantitation now a red would be a
scenario that I see absolutely nothing
the challenge becomes at some point is
to take all this data and put it into a
scenario of which method do I use now on
average by going with a 36 methods you
gain something around 85 to 90 percent
success rate that you'll find a method
that will work for any given compounds
now is also scenario that you have
certain methods certain compounds will
not work it just means that you have to
go through a another iteration of
different solvent different chemistry's
different loading conditions but this
particular scenario in a 6x6 grid gives
you a good reference in this case over
here when we look at the micro system
our our lry our and internal standard we
can see that we've taken out all these
boxes that actually are yellow or red
and concentrate on the one that gives
the best methods or the best score so in
this case will be here we've chosen
method 14 because it gives the highest
score and we can see here on the
right-hand side a representative of
chromatogram of separation for all three
compounds there's an aspect with this
particular scenario for injecting
high-level sample and both aqueous and
organic it actually changes how we can
to our sample prep now in this case will
be here the aspect of extraction
development for maximum recovery since I
do not need to evaporate the dryness
ever again
I can basically now spend some time on
the optimization and look at polarity of
my solvent but also looking at my pH and
basically found and find on a quick
experiment which method which condition
will give the best recovery in this case
will be here we went through a process
of actually evaluating at least nine
different solvent more can be utilize we
simply do an illusion and loading and we
aleut and we inject up to in this case
200 microliters now in this case will be
here we can see that we can get a quick
aspect and basically we have a clean
picture of how this component interest a
company of interest will react at any
given time so now in this case will be
here wouldn't feta means we know that
with a methanol Ellucian works better
than a neutral pH with no additive
either ph3 or pH 10 are better than ACN
and better not acetone so now this one
basically behave as a polar compound
once we have that it's actually one way
of actually looking at how multi
dimension chromatography can have an
impact on your workflow another aspect
over here is that we can create what we
call a sequential illusion now this one
is actually a very interesting
application because in this case we can
have a clear picture of how a compound
interest is eluding off a cartridge so
it's not a matter of actually guessing
it's a matter of basically utilizing the
same concept as a comprehensive
chromatography idea is to slice your
sample into discrete packet and
understanding where your company of
interest is alluding so now once we
actually put all these results in this
case will be here you can see that you
have multiple extract but in the course
of several hours or an evening run or no
over that run all those results
we delivered the next morning now by
tabulating these results into a graph we
can see exactly how it compounds behave
now for example RR starts alluding at
20% ACN on the low pH but basically
spread between 20 up to 40% now at high
pH we can see that it actually has a
tighter band between 20 and 30 so RR
behave as a basic entity compared to a
methanol at low or high pH so this
actually gives an opportunity if
compounds interest behave the same to
fine
section between this graph as to what
could be used for effective washes but
also effective allusions one would not
need to go up to a hundred percent of
Illusion but basically go through a
scenario that we can go at a lower
percentage that means that we can leave
a lot more interferences behind and
still lock onto the sorbent and
basically just do a very narrow cut on
the sample prep for these scenarios in
effects we are doing here what we call
heart cutting the next stage of the year
this one is interesting because we can
go a bit more bold on our sample prep by
using what it called a Newell stage
illusion so now in this case suppose
that we have very little information as
to the type of behavior a target analyte
could be so are we looking at a compound
that's an S acid-base neutral are these
compounds behaving as acidic or basic
one would not know so this one here
could be utilize as a screening aspects
now here we would end up with four final
extracts now depending on where the
compounds are we can actually see which
one works best and which one resemble
one another for example in this case
will be here we have
a add on exchanger on top and then we
have a common exchange on the bottom so
now I have here two type of compounds
obviously there are pesticides from the
organophosphate family and from the
carbonate family so they actually have
an amine structure and a phosphate
structure so now on the MX Ellucian one
we're talking about the hunter percent
organic with no additive now the mx2
would be the low pH solution to get
everything off down exchanger now MC x1
and m62 would be the reverse phase of
the second dimension to see if there's
actually any breakthrough so now we have
here a kind of an assurance that if it's
not retained by the first stage it would
be retained by the second one so now if
these compounds behave as basics they
should be retained on a reverse phase
portion of this orbit so we can see that
we have three compounds on your hand
that have a switcher type of behavior
now the rest actually utilizes neutral
we have here a very durable real ocean
rate between 75 up to 94 which is
actually typical of what we could see
for these stuff the compounds but
interesting enough for a carbonate even
though they have an amine structure some
will behave as strictly as acidic
they're not retained at all on a reverse
phase some will remain as neutral as
this bows some will actually showcase
Hib behavior but one in particular out
of the whole scenario has a basic
functionality means not retained by
reverse phase it's not retained by an
exchanger but it's actually retained by
the a portion actually break through in
this case so it gives kind of a really
good idea of what multi D can actually
do and after
gives us a lot more information about
the behavior and the prospect the
property physical and chemistry of our
talk and light now those were actually
aspect of how we can use a simple trap
and Aleut type of configuration there's
actually multiple that we can do now if
resolution is actually the scenario to
go in this case will be here we have
what we call a loop trap can be
configuration so we take a heart cut
from my first dimension and we can park
it into a in this case a loop and push
everything of that loop on to a trap for
peak refocusing so now that means the
dimension 1 and dimension 3 which are
the high resolving dimension can be
operated independently from one another
and it's a bit different from the dual
loop combination now this one here the
loop between dimension 1 in the mission
3 can be optimized for different
applications we can have a scenario that
we're looking at let's say an HPLC high
flow rate UV and we can go towards a upl
CMS for example so that means that we
can get a validated method in HPLC and
get ms data without having to change the
method now for example here we have on
the left-hand side under green red
rather from a de gram we have an
application that was done on a standard
C 18 column under UV condition this
actually is a standard four point six a
2.1 by a hundred rather and we see that
peak hnk are basically alluding our coil
ooting together so now on our second
injection you notice that we have the
hard cut and we can actually send that
pair to a different column chemistry in
this case we here we're using an HSS t3
on one side
and we're using a phenol on your side to
separate now phenol makes a lot of sense
because in this case these two target
analytes are final 18 in nature they
have a very similar backbone with the
difference between an iodide and a
sulfur group and we can actually
separate those two better on a phenol
than on a standard cetane another aspect
will be here that we can use is the same
scenario we have another coalition that
happens in this instance and by going
from AC 8 to a phenol we see that we
have now structural isomers that
basically can be resolved very well for
this form so now in this case will be
here depending on how many hard cuts do
I want then I will have to add as much
as loop injection as the last one here
we can see that we have a scent that
cannabinoid so now we're going from a
sniper C 8 to a pair floral application
so the concept here is the scenario that
we can harness or heart cut either a
single heart cut or multiple heart cut
for resolution purpose so now this
brings to the last slide and I think
it's actually a conclusion we here that
I'd like to leave all of you with the
main issue that I've seen over the years
when we talk about more right actually
when I talk about the concept it's this
deep perception of difficult to
understand we operate in that case
scenario that it's not that case typical
workflow today will have a very complex
sample prep and usually will lead to
poor performance and that's actually
where the scenario is right now single
dimension chromatography has reached a
limitation so that's actually where the
new article platform with a
multi-component multi chemistry
application or workflow walk she will
give you in the end
a novel workflow means that you can
anticipate looking at a technology of
that nature that has
a lot of benefit and cost reduction time
resource and consumable it will optimize
your sample prep protocols usually that
will go from days down to hours some
time minutes and it will also increase
resolution performance it's actually a
very addictive technology once you taste
this you never go back so this is
actually in fact the presentation and
work hope you enjoyed it thank you for
your time